also in Studio City at at one time this
is all in the book um you thought that
uh somebody had put a a um a rat or a
rat had died in the
dumpster yeah in my trash can actually
it was my physical trash can I didn't
know what it first the woman from across
the alley in Studio City I know she's
never going to want to see she hadn't
seen me for 35 years she not going want
to see me anymore but trust me I had
nothing to do with any of this but I the
neighbor lady across the way said is
your cat Okay I said what do you mean is
my cat Okay my cat's fine I'm afraid it
crawled under the house and died I don't
think so I saw it just earlier oh there
it is there's my cat my cat's fine
there's my cat okay I think a cat died
under
your oh God yeah I can smell it but it's
not a cat I said to her I said it's a
rat because I just been at a friend's
house and in the Attic a rat had died
and I thought that was a smell unique to
rats it is not it's a mammal and they
smell basically alike when they're
decomposing so I and then I picked up
the lid to the trash can cuz it seems to
be coming from my trash can whoa
something I said somebody hit a dog or
something or maybe something bigger look
like what is that and I covered it up
somebody must have hit a dog and put it
in the dumpster because they didn't want
to deal with the the liability of
killing someone's dog so I went to the
bank and said call the animal control
and I'll be back in a little while and
need to talk to me I came back it wasn't
Animal Control there's all these
detectives and cops and I can't get in
my back gate with my bike and I go
through the front there's a cop waiting
for me he says Mr Begley can you uh such
and such where do you live I said I live
right here what's the problem I was
trying to look over the fence stay stay
with me do not go near the fence Mr
Begley please okay so what's this about
and I he said have you seen anybody near
your place dumping anything unusual I
said no what happened what's is there
something in my dumpster somebody hit an
animal no no never mind stay away from
the fence please so of course now
hearing all this I got to get up on the
roof and see what's out there what still
you know your mind doesn't work like
that you don't think what am I you know
you think is it a dog what the hell is
it I went what is that is that like a
saddle with oh my God that's a torso
that's a head that's two arms that's two
legs they had it all laid out and
they're taking pictures of this person
who was cut up and left in my dumpster
did you fig did you find out who it was
about 6 months to nine months later
there picture in the paper and he went
oh yeah that's somebody I had a drink
with no that poor woman I never met it
was a woman a young woman I just 15
years sad sad to think about how that
woman what happened to that took her
from her mother's arms to that trash can
there Studio City I can't I don't want
to think about I can't imagine that was
in front of your house it was in my
alley right in the back of my alley it
was it was my oh no two other body parts
were my friend James Jeremiah's alley
I'm sorry your friend your it's just
around you it's just you and your live
down the block for me then and just you
and your friends me and James Jeremiah
yeah how is this happening to you well
nothing's really happening to me it's
kind of happening to these other poor
just all around you it seems to be
around me I know
hey